مساء الخير المظاهرات المشتعله في السودان
على مدار الاسبوع الماضي لكن عمليه تقدير
موقف تطورات الاحداث هناك سيناريوهات
دقيقه مساله صعبه جدا لثلاث اسباب السبب
الاول ان حاله التعديل المفهومه من جانب
الحكومه السودانيه اللي يعني ما
يخرج عنها اي تقدير للموقف ولا بيانات
دقيقه
بطبيعه ما يجري على الارض هناك الامر
الثاني حاله تعتيم ايضا من جانب الحكومات
العربيه التي ت تعامل بحذر شديد مع ما
يجري في السودان لانهم تعلموا درسا بشار
للاسف في سوريا فتوقفوا لا هم يريدون
التعبير عن دعمهم بشكل واضح مع الحكومه
السودانيه او الرئيس السوداني ولا هم في
نفس الوقت بسرعه
للتعاطف مع ال او دعم المعارضه حتى لا
يتورطوا كما تم في اه اه سوريا من 2011
الامر الثالث حاله عدم اقتراض وتجاهل
الجانب الحكومات العربيه
والمساله سببها بسيط جدا انه مفيش نشاط
يذكر للشركات الغربيه في السودان على مدار
سنوات طويله ولا شركات بطول ولا يعني اه
شركات تصنيع ضخمه ولا مصالح كبيره في
مصالح لكن مصالح محدوده وبالتالي انعكس
على المتابعات وسائل الاعلام المختلفه
اللي اكتفت بس في مره خبر يعني من وكالات
الانباء ان هناك مظاهره لهذه الاسباب
الثلاثه ما نقدرش بشكل واضح عندنا رؤيه او
تقدير موقف ل ممكن المظاهره الدين
لكن في كل الاحوال
يعني في اتجاهين للاحداث الاتجاه الاول او
السيناريو الاول انه يكون مصير هذه ال
المظاهرات مثل مظاهرات كثيره سبقتها على
مدار السنوات الماضيه يعني كان فيه
مظاهرات محدوده في بدايه في يناير الفين
وسبعه عشر احتجاجا ايضا على غلاء الاسعار
وتحديدا القدس ثم تم احتوائها وفي مظاهرات
كانت اعني في 2013 والعالم كله تبعها وكان
البعض يعتقد انها الربيع العربي الذي كان
متاخره الخرطوم وردت الحكومه باجراءات
عنيفه جدا ذهب ضحيتها نحو مائتين من
المتظاهرين
والاف من الجرحى والمعتقلين
تم تجاوز هذه
المظاهرات وعادت الامور الى مجاريها قد
يكون يعني مصير هذه المظاهرات اللي موجوده
في كثير من المدن الاكثر من ثلاث اشهر انا
باكلم حضراتكم قد يكون مصيرها مثلا مصير
مصير هذه المظاهرات السابقه
لكن في كل الاحوال لو تم احتواء المظاهرات
احنا قدمنا موقف واضح وهو انه سيتم اخماد
المظاهرات او احتواء ارضيه المظاهر
المتظاهرين بشكل او باخر لكن سوف يظل
الغضب مكتوم والنار تحت الرماد الاحتمال
الثاني ان تحدث مفاجئه وان تنجح هذه
المظاهرات في الاتساع بشكل يفوق قدره
الحكومه السودانيه او الرئيس عمر البشير
اللي اكتسب قدراتها الى جدا في التعامل مع
اشكال التمرد المختلفه على احتواء وفي
الحالي احنا بنتكلم على
المفاجاه الكبيره هو تنحي الرئيس عمر
البشير
علشان نتكلم على السيناريوهين بشكل واضح
لازم نفهم طبيعه المشاكل اللي موجوده في
السودان الصدري يعاني من مشكلتين كبار جدا
وعليه كبار بنتكلم على وضع اقتصادي تداعي
جدا
وبنتكلم على حاله جمود سياسي شديد
منذ على مدار يعني البنيه او الجمود اكتمل
على مدار حوالي ثلاثين سنه لو تكلمنا على
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه علشان تفهم والسودان
حجم الماساه اللي موجوده في السودان وليه
اي احتواء للمظاهرات لن يكون الا حل مؤقت
وسوف يستمر الغضب وتجدد المظاهرات مره بعد
مره لوف يهمنا مجموعه من الارقام تشرح لنا
الوضع في السودان عندنا السوداني بتكلم
على شمال الصدام طبعا
حوالي اربعين مليون نسمه
الاربعين مليون نسمه دول الديلي في ابنته
المحلي الاجمالي في شمال السودان او
للسودان يعني تفرقه له من جنوب عندهم
السودان بنتكلم على في حدود لغايه 2017
تبقى التقديرات البنك الدولي بنتكلم على
حوالي مائه وسبعه عشر مليار دولار المائه
سبعه عشر مليار مليار دولار دول بيمثله
تقريبا من الناتج المحلي الناتج الاجمالي
للعالم اللي هو اربعه وسبعين مليار تقريبا
اربعه وسبعين مليون اسف نتكلم على تسعطاشر
من واحد في المائه يعني يعني تقريبا خمس
من واحد في المائه وبنتكلم على انه اقل
بشكل كبير جدا
مثلا من دوله تعددها حوالي اثنين ونص
مليون زي دوله القطر الى الجنوب يبتاعها
حوالي مائه اربعه وثمانين مليار اه دولار
وبالتالي ناتج محلي محدود عندنا نسبه
التضخم يعني ارتفاع الاسعار واحده من اعلى
المعدلات في العالم
والارقام متباينه لكن بتتكلم على تتجاوز
الخمسه وستين في المائه في الشهور الاخيره
بيتكلموا على ثمانيه وستين وتسعه وستين في
المائه معدل ارتفاع الاسعار
العمله وطبعا التضخم مرتبط بالانخفاض
الهائل في العمله كانت الحكومه السودانيه
عملت تغييرا وتخفيض قيمه العمله تحت ضغط
انعدام العملات او مصادره العمله الاجنبيه
فكان الجنيه السوداني على ما اذكر ب سته
وسبعه سته وسبعه مقابل الدولار يعني كله
سوى سته من تسبب على ما اذكر هي رفعته الى
التي انخفضت الى ثلاثين بقي الدولار يساوي
في الصوت الرسمي ثلاثين لكن في السوق لكن
انعدام نتيجه عدم توفر الدولار لانه ما
فيش لصادرات كفايه ولا استثمار ولا غيره
فالحياه في السوق السوداء تجاوز رقم اثنين
واربعين لما تشوف حجم العجز الميزان
التجاري السودان بيصدر بدايه وتستورد
بتلاقي العجز ما بين الصادرات والواردات
حوالي مائه في المائه يعني هما بيصدر
حوالي اربعه
بيستوردوا بثمانيه وثمانين
مليار طبعا يعني احنا نتكلم عن العجز في
حدود المائه في المائه لما تتكلم على
الاحتياط يعني بدايه موجود احترافيه البنك
المركزي السوداني
تقديرات صندوق النقد الدولي انه الغايه
ديسمبر اللي هو الشهر اللي احنا بنتكلم
فيه احد يتكلم على وان
واحد مليار ومائه مليون دولار بدون يكفوا
واردات السودان لمده سبعه اسابيع معناها
فيه يعني عمليه بال جدا والاقتصاد
السوداني جدا جدا اللي ممكن اقول لكم على
ارقام من هنا الى ما شاء الله كلها بتقول
بتظهر حجم الاقتصاد السوداني مازوم ما
تشوف ال مؤشرات الاداء الدوليه اللي هي
مؤشرات توافق عليها تختلف عليه لكن هي
بتحدد اتجاهات الاستثمار في العالم كله
يعني لما تشوف مثلا
مؤشر سهوله اذ بيزنس اللي بيان صدر عن ال
ال البنك الدولي بيسموه مؤسسه سهوله
الاعمال وضع السودان في مائه اثنين وستين
من مائه وتسعين دوله
لما تشوف مؤشر الحريه الاقتصاديه اللي
بينتج عنه اللي بتصدره مؤسسه
الامريكيه مائه وواحد وستين مائه وسته
وثمانين دوله لما تشوف
اه ترتيب السودان في مؤشر مدركات الفساد
2 ترتيب مائه وخمسه وسبعين من مائه
وثمانين دوله وهو يتقدم هو افضل من مين هو
اسوء من كل دول العالم الى ما عدا اربع
دول ال اربع دول هي افغانستان وسوريا
والصومال وجنوب السودان اللي هم دول
انهكتها الحروب تماما لما تشوف تقرير الكم
تقرير التنافسيه الدوليه واحد من عدد من
الدول اه يعني لم يشملها التقرير من اساسه
وبالتالي تجاوزها من الاساس لم يتحدث عنها
خارج التصنيفات هو لانه ما فيه ولا فيه
اهتمام
بالسودان من المجتمع الاعمال الدولي بدايه
من سبعه وتسعين لما فرضت العقوبات
الامريكيه على السودان بشكل عنيف جدا
وبالتالي خرجت تقريبا كل الشركات الدوليه
وحتى لما رجعت ال لما رفعت العقوبات
بمساعده من دول الخليج لما الرئيس ال عمر
البشير بدا انه ياخذ موقف يعني معهم ضد
ايران كانت النتيجه محدوده لانه البلد في
حاله تداعي بالنسبه للاقتصاد الماليه اللي
تكلم بالنسبه للوضع السياسي لو حبيت
الخاصه بدون ما قصروا بوش والصور
التجميليه تقدر مشكله السودان ان هذا
البلد العظيم اللي عارف الحريات السياسيه
وتداول السلطه والاحزاب
وال اه والصحافه بدايه من اواخر
الاربعينات والخمسينات والستينات
دول كثيره مش بس من الدول العربيه ولكن من
دول العالم الثالث والان في واقع الامر
ليس دوله بمعيار المفهوم الحديث يعني دوله
فيها سلطه مركزيه ولا دستور واضح مؤقت
طبعا ودستور دائم واضح وعندها حدود ليست
بحل النزاع من الطرف داخليه وعندها احزاب
وعندها برلمان وعندها الكلام دا الحياه
انه السودان اقرب الى رقعه فيها الان وهذه
الرقعه الجغرافيه في عدد كبير تضم عدد
كبير من العرقيات البشر ذوي العراقيات
المختلفه والديانات المختلفه وكثير من
اماكن السودان ما زال محل نزاع لما الغريب
جدا او من الامور المثيره الى ال يعني
الاسم انه لما حصل الانقلاب العسكري الى
قاده الجنرال عمر البشير الرئيس عمر
البشير الان ضد حكومه الصادق المهدي زعيم
حزب الامه الان اللي هو كانت حكومه
ديمقراطيه واتهمت بالعجز عن اداء كان احد
اسباب ال ال الانقلاب على حكومه الصادق
المهدي هو عجز هذه الحكومه سنه تسعه
وثمانين في انها تتعامل مع كثير من مشكلات
السودان الاقتصاديه الان بعد التسعه
وعشرين سنه تقريبا سته مده رئاسيه مختلفه
اه تنتهي عشرين القادمه العام الان ال
الكلام دائر في تبديد المسرح السياسي
الدستور بحيث سيسمح للرئيس عمر البشير
بتولي مده او مدد على الاقل
في الفتره المقبله في حاله تكلف تكلف
انه حالتهم وضعف في الاحزاب وتعرف في
عمليه التمثيل النيابي للشعب بس كمان
كلامك جدا في دول عربيه كثيره لكن الدول
العربيه كثير فيهم حاجتين ان كثير من
اطراف السودان او من اطرافها هي في حاله
تمرد على السلطه المركزيه يعني بعد ماساه
انفصال الجنوب
انفصال الجنوب اللي تم في 2011 بعد
معارك داميه بدات من يعني سنه خمسه وخمسين
يعني من اللحظات الاولى الانفصال او
لاستقلال السودان على الاحتلال البريطاني
احنا بنتكلم على فصل خلاص اه اه فاصل
انفصال تام في 2011 دوله هو ب السودان
ونجد انه في نفس هذا العام وبعدها باقل من
عده اسابيع تجدد الصراع وانتقل الصراع الى
منطقه كردفان ولا منطقه النيل الازرق او
ولايه الى الازرق وفي نفس هذه الاثناء كان
الصراع مش تعم ومازال يعني الوضع هادئ
انما مازال منطقه دارفور بتعاني من اثار
حرب شرسه جدا استمرت على اكثر من عشر
سنوات
فاحنا
الدوله طبعا بتعاني من اثار كل هذه
الصراعات وب تعاني من اثار الانفصال انتم
تعرفون الناس اللي هم السودان السودانيين
طبعا عارفين انه ثلثي
السودان من البترول اللي هو بردو محدود كل
ذهب الى جنوب السودان وحتى العوائد اللي
نتيجه نتيجه نقل البطوله على الاراضي
تداعب جدا توصل الى حوالي مليار تداعت
وانخفضت جدا الحروب والماسي اللي موجوده
في جنوب السودان حرمت الشمال حتى من هذا
نحنا عندنا ازمه اقتصاديه كبيره لا ينتظر
منها انه اه
يحدث انفراج قريبه وعندنا تكلفه هبوط
واضطرابات ونزاع على الحركات الانفصاليه
موجوده في الجنوب
ودا مش امر شائع في كل الدول العربيه اللي
فيها مساله الجميل يعني ده بيزيد في
السودان الامر الثاني الى موقف السودان و
مش موجود في دول اخرى خلاف النزعات
الانفصاليه الكثيره يعني هو انه الرئيس
عمر البشير هو الرئيس الوحيد في العالم
اللي موجود في السلطه وم لاحق من المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه يتهم
جرائم ضد ال جرائم وجرائم ضد الانسانيه و
مذابح جماعيه مع يعني طبعا حرب دراسه
كل ده معناها انه الرئيس يشعر باي قلق
شديد والنظام يشعر بقلق شديد من اي
اضطرابات وتضطر الى معدات هذه الاضطرابات
بعنف شديد لانه المساله مش بس يعني رغبه
في السلطه
ولكن خوفا مما قد ينتج عن اي محاوله او اي
شيء ممكن يؤدي الى تنحيه عن السلطه لانه
في هذه الحاله قد يكون مصيره انه الرئيس
المقبل قد يسلمه الى محكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه وهذا امر يعني لا يمكن ان يقبل به
الرئيس عمر البشير
وبالتالي احنا قدمنا سيناريوهات
السيناريوهين اذا اذا تم احتواء المظاهرات
كما حدث من قبل احنا قدام ازمه لم تحل سوف
يظل الغضب قائم الان كل ما طالب
المتظاهرين الاقتصاديه لا تستطيع الحكومه
بالامكانيات اللي انا قلت ال حضراتكم على
انتو فيها عن حلول لها ولما بتشوف
المسؤولين وهم بيتكلموا بيقولوا
قدره
الجزائر فاننا عندي ازمه فاقدي للناس من
عوائد الغاز ولادي
مثلا في السعوديه ارضي الناس عوائد ولا
حتى امكانيه مصرفه اننا اخفف الضغط من هنا
واعمل مشروعات تبتلع البطاله من هنا ما
عندوش خالص وطبعا هو مش فرنسا وبالتالي هو
عاجز عن احتواء ممكن يحدث انه وراء
الكواليس انه احد الدول يعني تتفاوض مع ان
تكون من دول الخليج دول الفائز نسبيا واه
ت تضع وديعه بملياري مليار خمسه مليار لاي
سبب ويتم التفاوض على مقابلها ايام الحل
جزء مؤقت لكن لن يكون حل دائم اما اذا تم
زي ما قلت لحضرتك م السيناريو الثاني
واجبرت المظاهرات الرئيس عمر على التنحي
فالسودان سوف يكون مفتوحا على كل
الاحتمالات
السيء منها والكيف منها لانه البدائل ليست
جاهزه في الوقت الراهن بعد ان يعني تم
تفجير او اختياريه لتبرير لكل الكفاءات
السياسيه اللي موجوده في السودان ويكون
المساله انه ها
العنصر الحاسم فيها ليس الشعب نتيجه ضعف
المؤسسات السياسيه ولكن المؤسسات العسكريه
الجيش يعني اقصد والدول الاقليميه في مصر
وفي السعوديه وغيرهم وال القوى الدوليه هي
لا تحسب خلافه الرئيس عمر البشير
اتمنى كل الخير لاشقائنا في السودان
وارجوا منهم باعتبار انهم موجودين على
الارض اللي هن شاركوا معانا و يوضحوا لنا
بتعليقاتهم حقيقه ما يجري هناك وتصوراتهم
لما يجري ومستقبل السودان اشكركم والى
لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
ام